Good antibiotics help in combating my type of cancer.
So, antibiotic use is an off-label use of medication in the caracology protocols.
So, we've had people do some of those protocols for helping with cancer.
It's really hard to measure the success or not,
because they're doing so many other things.
So, it's hard to know if any other people could chime in that maybe they were doing everything
and their cancer was going the wrong way and they added some of the off-label drugs
and their cancer turned around and started going the right way.
I don't remember anybody off the top of my head that had that experience.
I'm actually there's maybe a few people on this call that have done the off-label drug use.
So, I don't know. As far as your particular cancer, I'm not sure if I can't make the comment
if that would be true in your case. And using the antibiotics, I don't remember
that was one of the things that most of our patients shine one of the off-label drugs that most
of our patients shine away from because of the damage to the microbiota that is definitely going to
happen when you're doing that. Are probiotics a better approach?
Well, I don't think that probiotics is a cancer treatment is an approach.
Probiotics help your microbiota but it's not really a cancer treatment approach.
Okay, so the person that asks this question, I believe, is a person that has an open wound.
The other thing that can help with an open wound is using probiotics
topically. So, I've had numerous cases where using a probiotics
topically, meaning you have a capsule that you open up, and it should not be a spore probiotics.
So, there should be just a regular probiotic, not a spore probiotic if you know the difference.
So, it'll say it right on the packaging. This is probiotic spore typically we called spore
something like IG spore or mega spore or something. So, a done spore probiotic where you just sprinkle
a little bit of the, you know, open up a capsule and it sprinkles a half the capsule on the wound every day.
Okay, we've had some pretty cool results with that. You could think about doing that.
But taking it orally, I don't think that's going to have much of an effect on a cancer.
Of course, unless the cancer is like, you know, in the esophagus or in the, you know, in the
Diwad no area or something like that. What do you think about a rec stump therapy? That is a medication.
I legally can't even comment on that. So, you suggested cutting down a lion's
made. This is a latest cheek swab. Could you please advise why? That's just because that's what came
up in the testing. About a month now, I periodically have muscle spasms on my right shoulder.
First three weeks had happened while I laid in bed. No, it just spasms anytime, but periodically,
could this be linked to the cancer? So, this person has had a neck cancer and yes, it could be
affecting just the space-occupied lesion of the cancer, where the cancer is. It could be affected
in the brachial plexus. That's the nerve plexus that's coming out of the cervical spine.
And it goes also backwards to the rhubboids and the trapezius muscles. And that could definitely be
causing some of the spasms. Going to the chiropractor, getting those work done can be
helpful. Anything you can do to decrease inflammation can be helpful. Ice using ice, hot cold
packs can be helpful. Using a tens unit could be helpful. Any anti-inflammatory nutrition could